und für uns in minsk ist yasemin yahoo
semin du hast gestern die proteste
natürlich wieder begleitet wie lief das
ganze dann vor allem auch in den
abendstunden ab ja auch gestern in den
abendstunden waren die proteste
weiterhin friedlich ich stehe jetzt aber
hier vor dem vor der untersuchungshaft
wo viele protestler gestern abend
hingezogen sind wo sie gerufen haben
lasst unsere gefangenen frei denn sie
wollen dass die oppositionellen das 4000
gefangenen die in diesem gefängnis
momentan sitzen weil sie eben nicht
lukaschenko unterstützen freigelassen
werden sollen und auch heute sind hier
am morgen einige demonstranten vor ort
und warten darauf dass ihre angehörigen
freigelassen werden
unter anderem sitzt hier übrigens auch
der mann von der oppositionsführerin
zeit lernte yanofsky im gefängnis sie
ist ja untergetaucht in litauen
denn sonst wäre ihr hier dasselbe
passiert sie wäre auch ins gefängnis
gekommen sie hat sich aber jetzt mit
einer videobotschaft wieder gemeldet und
sagte sie ist bereit wiederzukommen sie
ist bereit die präsidentschaft zu
übernehmen
was erwarten denn die demonstranten
jetzt von deutschland und der eu wenn
man mit ihnen spricht ja also die
demonstranten hoffen natürlich auf hilfe
sie wollen dass politiker sie sehen sie
wollen dass politiker hinschauen das vor
allem auch deutschland hinschaut ist
eine frau merkel ein herr scholz
hinschauen damit sie sich einfach
sicherer fühlen denn wenn keine
politiker hingucken dann ist es so dann
haben die demonstranten natürlich angst
dass die polizei weiterhin gewaltbereit
bleibt dass die polizei weiterhin
inhaftiert gefoltert und das ein
lukaschenka einfach nicht gestürzt
werden kann
wir haben gerade auch immer wieder den
namen putin gehört als wir stimmen von
protestanten von protestlern gehört
haben weil welche rolle genau spielt
putin jetzt auch in diesen protesten in
diesem kampf der jetzt in minsk belarus
stattfindet naja man weiß ja dass putin
und lukaschenko telefoniert haben dass
putin lukaschenko entschuldigung dass
putin lukaschenko seine hilfe für den
ernstfall zugesagt hat was genau das
aber bedeutet ob das alles
ein riesen bluff ist oder ob putin ihn
wirklich zur hilfe lukaschenkos kommt
das bleibt alles noch unklar
und wie gehen die proteste jetzt weiter
sind andere aktionen geplant
also die proteste werden weiterhin
friedlich die proteste werden weiterhin
friedlich weiter gehen
man hat ja gestern auch gesehen weil der
größten demonstration bei 100.000
menschen die auf die straße gegangen
sind ist nichts weiter passiert was
heute erwartet wird sind aber die
staatlichen betriebe die streiken werden
und das könnte eben für lukaschenko
gefährlich werden denn er hat die
mehrheit schon nicht mehr auf seiner
seite und werden jetzt eben auch noch
die wirtschaft zusammenbricht wenn jetzt
noch die unternehmen sich von ihm
abwenden
dann könnte hier dann könnte das eben
gefährlich für seinen machterhalt werden